the liberal media is scorned for the
president is on full display trump's
been feuding with hostile reporters
during the taskforce briefings and for
good reason
check out this ridiculous gotcha
question american president loses more
americans over the course of six weeks
and died in the entirety of the vietnam
war does he deserve to be reelected so
yeah we've lost a lot of people but if
you look at what original projections
were 2.2 million
we're probably heading to 60,000 70,000
far too many one person who's too many
for this plus the view has a new target
dr. deborah birx the liberal host
attacking the medical expert for
defending trump i feel like at this
point she's less of a doctor and more
like an elderly care nurse to this guy
sunny you think that dr. Burke says is
part of the problem I do I do think
she's part of the problem and it gives
me no pleasure to say that you can't be
complicit in a time like this dr. Burks
and and and so I think she has become
part of the problem Wow alright well I
don't think I'm not even gonna address
the view ladies I thought that was way
way over the top Dana you know I've
asked my fare of gotcha questions before
I know how you play the game that woman
played it pretty well with the president
I just don't know if I could ever bring
myself to ask a gotcha question like
that to the President of the United
States have you ever seen anything like
that before do you think I have I ever
seen anything like that before so I work
for president during a time of war
torture memos I mean yeah I have seen
before and a little bit of that is just
you get into a chance where you have the
cameras on you know she's a reporter
that's written some pretty great things
she's broken a lot of stories she's also
writing a book about the 2020 election
so I think her question about does a
president like you deserve to be
re-elected was sort of geared towards
where she's thinking and where she's
your time but remember that look at the
president answered it so well so
sometimes it doesn't matter if the
question is hostile
if you hit a home run then who cares it
actually makes you look better can I
speak to the dr. Burke's thing for a
second way to stand up for women ladies
I mean Wow okay Joe Behar first of all
she's trying to look like dr. Burks with
the scarf it's something it's a look
that I can't pull off though I would try
at some point but here's a woman whose
responsibility is not to coddle anybody
she is supposed to try to manage a
pandemic and she's doing that with the
commander in chief so why don't we just
let her do her job for as long as she
needs to do it and to do it to her bet
the best of her ability and to do it
professionally which is what she has
been doing yeah she's been doing a very
good job Greg um I'm gonna play some
sound of another exchange again just
crazy crazy commentary from the press
corps the President and dr. Burks were
asked something and you can react to all
of it roll that nobody knows who you are
he asks a question and said you know
we're behind South Korea actually no
we're ahead of South Korea I mean these
are the kind of things that happen a lot
well I mean this is the environment it's
the gotcha question game show but I want
to do it I want to tie what Olivia newsy
and the Berks thing have in common
so Newsies question is the perfect
example of median narcissism the
question by its very nature is
guaranteeing attention back to the
person asking the question I'm sure she
got DMS from Acosta and the bald guy
saying wow that was really amazing what
you did to her but the question itself
is absurd do you deserve to be reelected
well that's what the election will
determine you [ __ ] and you can put it
like let's put it this way
given a Tornai
to hit your town and kill 30 people do
you deserve to be dog catcher
that's exactly how stupid her question
was now when you focus on bricks okay
it's called the contamination effect the
media love loves to just soil her
reputation because I've by signal if
you're hanging around somebody we hate
Trump then you are contaminated right
they transfer the hate to her so what
about the people that Burks knows right
are they contaminated by now knowing her
do you see how this thing works they
should do trace whatever they call
contact tracing on everybody's
friendships so lastly why do these
things have something in common
the media is hypocritically evil they
think that when they interview unsavory
people they are imparting their good
moral fiber on them so when they
question Trump they're actually the
moral high ground which is gives which
is wide nosy had her absurd question but
when you like like Burks is among Trump
then you are the recipient of the
unsavory nosov Trump right that you are
now amoral by being around him so you
see the trick the media gets to decide
who gets to impart impart moral value
and it's always them but it's never you
that's a good point one what do you
think I think the press is supposed to
hold powerful people accountable and ask
questions now I think president Trump is
never shy never shy about saying hey
that's a crazy question or that's an
unfair question or that's a fake news
question but in this instance he didn't
do that he treated it seriously and as
Dana pointed out he gave what I think
was a pretty good answer from his
perspective he said the numbers are less
than what had been projected and then
tried to take credit for it so that's
what he didn't by the way I don't think
it's a it was a gotcha question I think
it's a real question I think there are
real questions to come like today about
you know banks and even some of the
borrowers upset about the SBA screw-up
with the computers they people can't get
loan people are upset about you know
these big companies you know some of
these auto companies the LA Lakers
getting loans and not small business
people have legitimate questions to ask
and I don't think it's illegitimate for
the President to answer them when
there's gotcha questions like who's the
leader of whose back to stand or
something Dana would know about that
kind of silly question okay that's a
gotcha question but these to me
legitimate questions well I think this
sort of it underscores the hypocrisy
because you know respectfully one if her
question was truly designed to provoke
conversation then why when she was
called out that her question was just
designed to provoke she responded quote
shut the F up and I think for for Joy
Behar that's just another example of
someone who uses a you know the media
platform to attack those who attack
women and she's a Hillary Champion and
she calls herself a feminist and yet
this opportunity she calls dr. Burks who
is a US Army colonel and literally led
the HIV vaccine global movement she's
received tons of commendation awards
under Democratic administrations
she managed 1.5 billion dollars worth of
budget she literally led PEPFAR and Joy
Behar reduces her to an elderly care
nurse now I could compare and contrast
joy Behar's resume to hers but I will
not I don't think I need to